Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for our 65th episode!
Already 65 episodes, right?
As the second week of January.
BAU BAU!
Good morning, Ruffians!
You know, the new year, new outfits, maybe there's some new Ruffians watching us today.
Maybe you haven't noticed though.
Who knows?
Well, take note of FUWAMOCO Morning.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
I wasn't too busy winking, no!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU, good morning, Ruffians!
Yeah, FUWAMOCO Morning a little bit different this morning, huh?
Can you look a bit different?
I wonder why.
Moco-chan, is that why you're winking?
To appeal to the Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan.
Yet again, there's been another Pero Sighting.
Really?
What?
I mean, considering, you know, you didn't see him for a new outfit.
Yeah, but, you know, if Pero was, you know, working at the shrine, then maybe, you know, he would still be working at the shrine for a little bit longer or something.
He's just everywhere, huh?
Well, this time, a Ruffian spotted him here.
Oh... That... Suika game has changed a little bit for you there, huh?
Why is Pero there?
You know, he's not a part of the evolution chart, right?
Food evolution chart!
Fruit.
No, fruit!
Fruit!
Pero's neither fruit nor food.
He's a beast, okay?
Yeah, you definitely wouldn't find him anywhere that says groceries.
No.
Yeah, but... I don't know... He kinda look at it.
Are you blurring your eyes a little bit?
He does kind of look like he fits in there right.
Do you see him, Moco-chan?
Maybe!
Slay him!
Ruffians!
I think he kind of fits there though.
No?
He fits in.
Interesting.
Are you blurring your eyes on Ruffians?
You have to really go like this.
Okay.
Yeah.
I can see it.
Well, you know, it's a good thing that we haven't updated our game recently, because if this is a new update...
You know, our game, as you saw before just now, it's still Pero-less.
Although there is the weird cloud high.
The cloud high!
No Pero, but the weird cloud that's apparently always been there.
Yeah!
But we just noticed.
But I guess you know...
Probably have just a little different game maybe.
Yeah, and we kind of took a peek at your score there.
And I don't know, I don't think we did much better than you did.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, you don't... I guess the game maybe... Your score is nothing to sneeze at though.
It's kind of our score too, right?
But, you know, I guess maybe the game... The game must just be harder because you have the Pero version, right?
So... Yeah, I guess you know.
FUWAMOCO... We'll try a bit harder Suica game!
But I bet you we have more fun than you, huh?
That's a threat!
Good luck!
Good luck with Suica game and the Pero version!
Good luck, you'll need it.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, you know, it's been a busy weekend.
A weekend full of very exciting events.
A lot of stuff!
And a big part of that just happened a few hours ago.
Did you know this?
Ruffians!
RuffianS!
I got a bit too excited.
Do it again!
Ruffians!
You can't do it!
It's not the same note!
When do you have to say hi?
Good morning.
When do you have to say it?
We did it, Ruffians!
All together!
We hit 700,000 Ruffians!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
How thankful we are to have you here laughing with us, sometimes maybe crying with us, and supporting us on this journey.
Thank you, Ruffians.
We know that it's not always easy, especially when you have your responsibilities.
And maybe, FUWAMOCO, we're kinda up to always something new.
Something troublesome.
But we want you to know that it means a lot to have you here with us.
So, thank you so much!
We hope that you'll continue to cheer us on lots and lots this year!
As you know, we explore and experience a lot of new things to come.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
Thank you, always, always!
BAU BAU!
1,000,000 and doing Twinkle Game!
It doesn't seem that crazy for FUWAMOCO to actually even think about it!
It's basically been a big endurance since last night, huh?
Right!
Basically!
But isn't it really fun?
Yeah!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Let's continue to have lots of fun in 2024 here.
It's just started, too!
It's just started!
Oh my goodness.
BAU BAU!
Oh, wow.
You know, this weekend
One of the other things that was really big.
You might already know it.
I don't know.
Maybe they haven't, you know.
Sometimes Ruffians, they don't know it's that high.
Sometimes, you know.
Yeah.
Wow.
Abyss!
We had our New Year Outfit Reveal Relay!
BAU BAU!
Did you notice something looks a bit different right now, huh?
What do you think, you know?
I'm still sleepy, I didn't know anything.
That's okay.
You have to open those eyes.
It's okay.
I understand, you know, but we revealed them to you at the start of the weekend.
We had like a big relay celebration together with all of Abyss, even though she's a
Shiori!
She has a very elegant kimono with a brush for her artisings!
Noe's very stylish and well-suited for her feathers!
And Biboo's super cute with her bonnet and the extra-thing pacifier.
You know, I think we were all destroyed!
But, how cute she looks.
Right?
Baby Biboo.
It's pretty cute.
It might be too cute.
Moco-chan, you feel threatened?
No!
No?
I'm not like Biboo, okay?
Yeah, you're not Biboo.
I'm not shameless.
That's just because you lost the Mario Kart, huh?
Uh, no, it's because I want to get back at Shiori too.
FUWAMOCO!
We look like this!
What do you think, Ruffians?
Quiet.
Cute!
Very pretty!
Bouncy twin tails.
BAU BAU!
Well, you know FUWAMOCO, we not only revealed our outfits, but we also sung one song because we wanted to share our feelings with you Ruffians.
And we thought it fit very well with our new outfits too, right?
Yeah, but after that, we dust off because we had a big collab stream.
Always busy.
I know, and we talked about New Year celebrations in Japan.
Yeah, it was a lot of fun.
Did you learn some stuff from me?
We kind of became FUWAMOCO-sensei a little bit.
Did you learn something?
Right up by the Abyssgard Shrine.
Right.
If you weren't able to catch it, please check it out!
You might learn maybe a new thing about
New Years in Japan, but you know, we ate wasechi ryori, we talked about hatsumode, and we drew omikuji fortunes all together.
Pero.
It's a bit confusing, but don't think about it too hard.
It wasn't just that though, because we also had a bunch of surprises too!
You know, now we have a new voice-chamber out with all of our friends.
Very Fugitive New Year!
Such a cute illustration too!
And this voice drama is different from the one that we had released near Halloween.
This time, you know, we traveled to Japan.
We had a bunch of fun in our brand new kimono.
Different food stalls.
Palmochi.
Yurandera.
All of those fun things.
But I think this time, you know, it was just so much fun.
Yeah.
I think we laughed.
We laughed a lot.
It's probably too much.
It's very Advent.
It's very, very Advent.
We hope that you'll check it out this time too!
Ruffians, have you had a chance to listen to it yet?
What did you think?
It was god tier!
Oh my goodness!
Fun!
Go go go!
It was great.
I'm glad!
It was really fun.
You have to watch!
We're the same.
BAU BAU Ruffian.
You know, that wasn't the only surprise!
Our new year outfits have also been added to the hololive Closet Acrylic Dance Collection!
Ruffians!
You can now pick us and add us to your collection with these new outfits too!
And you know the acrylics dance, they look really great together!
Ordered yours!
Did you order?
Oh you did!
Oh my goodness!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, we have one request though.
Please share your pictures of them once you receive them, okay?
Yeah.
Okay.
We can take them out in the snow.
If there's no more snow by that time, you can make some snow.
Right.
Lots of stuff.
Yeah.
But!
Well.
Finally.
Enough.
And then, we also released a brand new song cover of BABYMETAL's Megitsune all together!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Yeah, it's on the official hololive English channel, okay?
Have you listened?
No, it's our first time singing a metal song, so please check it out again!
It's amazing!
It was really good!
You heard it!
BAU BAU!
We were a little bit nervous, but Moco-chan, you were so cool!
I did my best, yeah.
And Ruffians' video is right!
Something else too.
Right!
Definitely need to check it out, but I think with FUWAMOCO, we both are really really happy because we thought that Shiori and Biboo really shined in it.
Yes!
I love Biboo's solo at the Ochi-sabi.
It's so good, it really ties everything together.
We were so happy listening to it when we heard it the first time.
And Shiori's part too, she really stands out and kind of like
Do give me chocolate when you guys do 3D!
We are really happy to be able to have all these special surprises for you Ruffians.
That was really, really fun and, you know, we hope that you'll decide to make it a very Adventful 2024!
Yes, Adventful.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for spending your holidays and your New Year time with us.
Let's continue to have a really fun 2024!
BAU BAU!
But!
This weekend, there was also something very big that happened.
Something else.
Yeah.
And actually, it just came and went.
It just ended.
Yeah.
It was the big whole new year cup that started yesterday and then just concluded today.
The finals.
Yeah, you know, over the weekend, us and Biboo and a bunch of our senpai, we all participated to see who would be crowned the best of all hololive.
The best of Mario Kart.
You know, it's a very serious competition.
You know that a lot of our senpai spent hours and hours and hours training for it.
And you know, FUWAMOCO,
We intended to do a decent amount of practice today.
We did!
That one.
But, it just happened that a lot of things kept getting in our way.
Yeah.
Like, you know, computer almost died.
Wasn't stressful, no.
But, you know, at least we still got to do one practice stream before the qualifiers.
The first and the last.
Yeah, but, you know, that's okay because I think we still excelled at
Doing our best!
And having fun!
That's amazing!
BAU BAU!
I think we did pretty well.
We did so well.
Qualifying matches, we actually even got twin scores!
Yeah!
We both got 9 points!
I don't know how that happened.
Right!
How silly is that, Ruffians?
9 points?
I was in Group B and Moco-chan Group A. Right.
That's what a weird high.
Very silly.
I know.
We also did our best in the semi-finals too!
Hapetate.
Ino.
In the end, we were placed into the Zako Cup category.
Are you saying they're wrong?
It's not right!
Ruffians, if you don't know what the Zako Cup is, it's for...
The player's not to worry about.
Maybe.
That's the nicest way to put it, huh?
You know, and in the end, we both got third to last!
Why?
But you know, it doesn't matter.
If you put it like that, it sounds really good though.
Yeah!
Word!
To last!
But we have to say the last part, Moco-chan!
We got third!
But we had fun!
We did!
Yeah, you know, more than anything, we were just really happy to be able to participate and play with our senpai.
I want to do more today!
Why does it have to be over?
Yeah, today.
Well, you had your chances done now.
I don't know, but Ruffians on top of that, Biboo!
Biboo got into the Tsuyo Cup!
Those are the Mario Kart plays you have to worry about.
The best of the best!
She did amazing!
She really did amazing!
We're so proud of her!
I rock!
Guess what, Ruffians?
She even got first place in one of the rounds.
That was so amazing!
All our senpai!
Oh my gosh.
I think we almost stood up out of our chairs.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Kind of on that topic of Mario Kart Ruffians.
It's not a misunderstanding.
No.
It isn't.
It's not a misunderstanding that we started.
No.
Yeah, there was something funny that happened.
Ah, well.
Yeah.
It seems like Hekora-senpai is trying to feel BAU BAU away from us.
Look at that!
Yeah.
Trying to steal it.
Doing the whole New Year's Cup Ruffians.
You know, we all had to come up with something to say to kind of threaten our points.
For some reason, Pekora-senpai decided to choose BAU BAU.
What's with the HA-Ruffians?
You know, Pekora-senpai has peko peko.
She can say peko peko.
Why is that no good anymore?
Why?
Huh?
Yeah.
You know, so... Ruffians, we thought we only have one choice, you know.
We need to crush her to be able to save BAU BAU.
BODY SLAM.
Annihilate.
Yeah, and... Ruffians, I don't... I don't think we did it.
I did our best.
But our best isn't gonna save BAU BAU!
Yeah.
Well, the only time we were able to beat Pekora-senpai was- was once.
But that was when she disconnected memories.
So... I don't think that counts as a win.
Right?
That doesn't count.
We didn't beat her with our- with our strength!
We didn't body slam her.
Yeah.
So...
Ruffians, I don't really know what the future has in store.
You know, we might have to stop using BAU BAU from now on.
Right?
You wouldn't want that, right?
Yeah.
Right?
If Pekora-senpai says, Hey, FUWAMOCO!
No BAU BAU!
She's our senpai, so... Yeah.
I know it's sad but our BAU BAU days might be numbered.
BAU BAU
Call the Oozora Police!
I don't know if we need to get the Oozora Police involved in this, you know?
That's kind of jumping ahead a bit.
Not like, bunny hops, but...
You know, leave some balance.
Alright.
Subaru-senpai will protect you.
Well, it seems like Subaru-senpai will be interested in that sort of thing, huh?
We did have a chat with her, you know.
So... We'll see you Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Well, you know, Ruffians, today, like every Monday, is the start to a new week.
And, well, it's always good to challenge yourself to something new, right?
Challenge yourself, right?
And, well, Moco-chan, you usually challenge yourself to natto, right?
Eating some natto, but, well, Moco-chan, you have something you wanted to say to the Ruffians, right?
Ruffians!
Is it okay if I ask you something?
Can you listen to me for a bit?
Is it okay if I don't challenge the natural today?
As you know, things have been a bit rough for me recently.
As you know, it's been rough.
So, I just don't feel like I can challenge it today.
I've been doing my best recently, but you know, it's been a bit harder than usual sometimes.
Yeah, I've been doing my best.
I think, you know, we all feel like this every now and then, you know?
I just need to rest for today.
Is that okay?
No problem.
That's nice, right, Moco-chan?
Thank you, Ruffians.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU.
Yeah, we did get some new Natto, though.
But, it'll be new next week, too.
If we believe.
BAU BAU!
Let's check out who's the Doggie of the Day for today!
Today's Doggie of the Day is...
Oh!
Today's Doggie of the Day is Ralph!
Ralph!
Ralph.
That's a good name.
You know, I think it's unlike any other Doggie of the Day so far, huh?
Right!
Yeah!
Ralph, you know, Ralph is pretty tiny too.
Maybe not a chihuahua, but... A bit tiny.
Don't get confused though, you know.
He's actually been around for a long time, just like us!
Just like us!
But we're stronger than him, huh?
Yeah.
But I think, you know, he's been protecting this Ruffian for a long time too.
But we'll protect you now.
Forget it, Ralph.
Forget about Ralph, hi.
How does Ralph BAU BAU?
Maybe kinda like...
I think like that.
Right?
Yeah.
Sounds about right.
Wow, you know, Ralph has been doing his all to protect this mouth for many, many years.
Despite the setback.
It's okay, we'll take it from here.
You know, his fur might be a little grey now.
Maybe, you know, the luster in his eyes is not as strong as other younger puppies like Fuwamoco.
But that doesn't matter!
He don't feel contented to be at your side for as long as you let him be.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you've been stretching those paws, right?
Let's see what you went for.
Today I went on a walk.
We have De-den!
Did you go on a walk?
A walk of a lifetime, maybe?
A big series of walks around Japan.
Sounds nice.
It looks like you maybe went to a lot of different places, saw a lot of different scenes, and maybe picked up some treasures too at the Tokyo Cat District hololive Store!
A good place.
Meet Ajiomoco-chan.
Right?
It sounds like you had some really good luck, huh?
Can't get these anymore, Ruffians!
They're gone!
Wow.
Well, we're really glad that you have luck on your side.
BAU BAU!
That's a good walk.
Next we have our Question of the Day!
Let's see what we have.
Oh!
I love your Pup Talks, Mococo!
I wonder, what kind of prep work do you do for your now famous BT?
For instance, how do you know or plan what to say or what's your source of inspiration for your talks?
Now famous, you're gonna make Moco-chan all nervous, Ruffians!
Why?
It's not hard, right Moco-chan?
Huh?
It's okay.
A bit embarrassed?
You know, I think Moco-chan is just right from the heart, right?
No inspiration or anything needed.
Yeah.
She just wants to help you and, you know, we've had some hard times too.
So, we try to think back to those times and maybe hope that any words we have can help you too.
Right?
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions today!
Please, please don't forget!
FUWAMOCO Morning happens three times a week, so that means there's a lot of questions that could be answered.
A lot of Doggy of the Days that we could crown the Doggy of the Days.
You know, Pero Sightings are only if you happen to see Pero.
You have to be lucky though.
We also have the FUWAMOCO Scoop!
There was no scoops today.
Ruffians, is your journalism doing okay?
Please let us know okay with the hashtag.
Hashtag FUWAMOCOSCOOP FWMCSCOOP or for others, hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
While we check out our next stream.
Things kind of changed up, Ruffians!
You know, well, the plan was that we'd be doing our 700k Suika Game endurance on Tuesday.
But, well... Some happy things happened.
And... It didn't quite work out like that.
No!
I'm not doing it again!
I'm not!
That's why, you know...
Well, it already kinda happened.
It happened.
Sorry.
FUWAMOCO is too powerful!
No!
Ruffians, you're too powerful!
Yeah, so you know, our next team is actually gonna be Wednesday's FUWAMOCO Morning.
Yeah, and after that, we're gonna be playing Sushi Soul Universe!
But in between that, FUWAMOCO, we'll make sure to get some good homework done, as well as some good rest too, because we've been going right!
Ruffians, make sure you take a good rest too.
You rest, we'll rest, and we'll have a bunch of fun on Wednesday with FUWAMOCO Morning and Sushi Soul Universe.
Rest is needed for everyone, Ruffians.
But we'll see you then again!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us here for FUWAMOCO Morning.
Maybe you stayed up all night just like us.
Maybe you're just waking up.
Regardless, we're happy to be able to see you bright and early today!
But, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians!
Ghost Something!
BAU BAU!
Lost My Soul!
Yuki!
BAU BAU!
Maekoto!
Nomocs!
BAU BAU!
Saks!
TV-chan!
BAU BAU!
Egg-sama!
Ash-chan!
BAU BAU!
Kuroinu!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!